[Musique]
par les enfants bon froid
patron loup ou musique qu'est ce que tu
racontes noces je ne comprends rien je
parle comme notre petit ami faute patron
de mou
ou louent ou loulou goût mais que dis tu
je dis que je descend vite raconté une
histoire de loup à mes petits amis ont
l'échelle
propos mme
bonsoir
une histoire de loup oui une nouvelle
aventure de loulou le petit foc
attentes et cher ami un instant je me
pose
ecoutez-moi attentivement nous écoutons
amis gagnent deviendra il doit aller à
l'école décidé un beau jour le marin
pêcheur breton
et le lendemain matin un cartable sur le
dos yann partis ailleurs pour l'école
nous domaine aura linchet rubin
lorsqu'il se réveilla comme à
l'accoutumée il pris son bain est que la
mousson de l'eau tout autour de lui
il ouvrit le placard aux provisions il
chipe à quelques galets
ah non ce n'est pas bien à ça mais la
maison lui semblait très vide il se
sentait tout seul et tout perdu sans son
amie anna la pauvre alors on se
dandinant sur ses nageoires il parti lui
aussi à l'école
berrichonne a perdu son chat chantaient
les écoliers
à
répondit le petit foc en frappant contre
le carreau ma parole mais chasse aux
phoques
bien dit la maîtresse puisque ce fox 30
et que cela fait plaisir aux enfants je
l'autorisent à suivre les cours de sa
cour à vivre notre gentille maîtresse
s'écrièrent en choeur les écoliers ravis
et dont la petite île fait de
coquillages de sable et devant le marin
pêcheur breton avait maintenant un
bateau une femme une maison un petit
garçon et un petit haut qui s'achève un
petit pack qui chantait à ap ap ap ap ap
et voilà l'histoire est terminée
déjà elle était très jolie moi je les
aime beaucoup l'hôtel ou des livres dit
tenez
rami son vaisseau
bonne nuit mes amis de l'art ou
l'eau-de-vie que nous tous mes voeux
vous accompagne
[Musique]
et
gagner notre nounou aux patrons je suis
content lavieu belle vous ne trouvez pas
oui nounours la vie est très belle on
lit vor en route manille les enfants
faute de beaurains
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
oh
[Applaudissements]
encore
m